hell of a presidential race sir
same damn coke hella make you out of
Barbara and poor choices with security
at unprecedented levels this isn't just
a gathering of the world's most powerful
leaders it is the most protected event
on earth welcome to London mr. president
what's wrong
nothing bugs the hell out of me has
decimated the British capital
I thought the world's leaders are now
dead
we'll get you out of here the American
president
is unaccounted for to our friends in the
West Rockaway number six on the ten list
what do you want your president that's
not going to happen then every dare from
this moment forward will be on your head
we have to find a coward before he fires
the president we're going to kill him
slowly and broadcasted live yeah well
you should have brought more men
I will not be executed as propaganda
you don't let them take me it comes to
an auditory that's an order London is
just the first start
just imagine every major city this
into chaos your president dies tonight
for those who threaten our freedom
America will rise up
and make no mistake
we will find him
and we will destroy you
Mike we're getting you out
moved our 3 o'clock breaks right back
oh my god but this is the light